hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to red dead redemption - now
I've been looking forward to this game
for a long long time because before I
started YouTube in the transition period
between when I was not happy and when I
started making videos I played one game
one and it was Red Dead Redemption every
spare moment that I wasn't working on
some other weird project before I went
into YouTube
I was playing Red Dead Redemption it was
so fun it was so free and I just loved
the environment of it so I'm going into
this completely eager to see everything
but I think you can forgive me for a few
things number one I will probably be
doing a lot of cowboy voices I that's
just a blanket sweep you got to agree to
that's going into this because I don't
even know if I'm gonna be able to help
it number two I am NOT a console gamer
and I'm playing this on PlayStation 4 so
I don't think that I'm going to be any
sort of good at aiming specifically if I
was mouse and keyboard I would tear this
[ __ ] up three ways from Sunday but as it
stands I'm playing on a keyboard or
playing on a controller so forgive me
when I'm bad at shooting but if I figure
out a way to get this click keyboard and
mouse setup into the into the old
PlayStation there I might actually be
able to do some good but until I can do
that I'm a stick it to the original way
that I played it before with the
controller so without further ado I'll
let's get into the story of this
by 1899 the age of outlaws and
gunslingers was at an end there ago the
first sentence that I read I got to do
it
yeah whatever America was becoming a
land of laws was it now we'll see about
that I think when I step onto the scene
it's not gonna be that easy even the
West had mostly been tamed you know this
is a prequel to the first game I believe
I'm pretty sure that's the story here
a few gangs still roam but they were
being hunted down and destroyed I like
this it seems like it's written on a
chalkboard it kind of gives that
educational history lesson feel to it
Rockstar Games presents Red Dead
Revolver 3
god I'm excited god I'm excited oh my
god I've been looking forward to this
for a long long time and it's been a
while since I just sat by and played a
game I didn't even know if I was gonna
be recording this game because I was so
eager to see it but man I couldn't pass
up oh no we were fooled
Skyrim again god damn it they keep
remaking it and we keep falling for it
oh here we go
Aaron Garbett I think you've probably
done a smash-up job here dan Houser
Michael whatever that third name I sent
him up if we don't stop soon we'll all
be dying whether it's May I'm just
hoping the law got as lost as we did
there Arthur better luck
I found a place where we can get some
shelter let Davi rest well he you know
an old man in town man hey come on okay
I'm sure that's good apparently these
guys are some kind of bandits and I
don't know if that's good whoa I love
the styling that's something that I
gotta say about Red Dead Redemption I
mean the whole Western theme is kind of
an played out in a lot of ways but when
it comes down to the style of the West
oh oh man it's something to really be
enjoyed chapter one
Colter so I got subtitles on everything
should be good to go on all the other
departments should be smooth going from
start to finish at this game and I am
gonna finish this game Oh better butter
your biscuit I'm gonna finish this game
bring who in here hello
mmm-hmm no miss Gaskill get that fire
lit quick Miss Jones bring in whatever
blankets we have mr. Pearson see what
we've got in terms of food Davey's dead
no there was nothing more you could have
done what are we gonna do we need
supplies well first of all you're gonna
stay here and you were gonna get
yourself warned
now I sent John and Mike a scouting out
ahead
Arthur and I we're gonna ride out see if
we can find one of them yes just for a
short bit and I don't see what other
choice we have come on Arthur listen to
me all you for a moment
now we've had a bad couple of days
I loved Davey Jenny
Sean Mack they might be okay we don't
know but we lost some folks now if I
could throw myself in the ground in
their stead
I'd do it gladly but we're gonna ride
out and we're gonna find some food
everybody we're safe now Barry no book
following us through a storm like this
one and by the time they get here well
we're gonna be we're gonna be long gone
we've been through worse than this
before mr. Pierce mrs. Crenshaw I need
you to turn this place into a camp we
may be here for a few days now all you
all are you get yourselves warm stay
strong stay with me we ain't done yet
now that's a leader come on Arthur
that's a leader come on Arthur we gotta
do some stuff they both must have headed
down the hill
I had time to ask me what really went
down back there on that boat we miss you
this with that come on hey horses oh
yeah hey mr. Smith
yes yourself indoors arrest him I'll
live get in George Sun oh what a good
guy
this guy don't seem like he's doing too
good though this leader guy I think he
might have been shot at some point also
this is really throwing me because I
just
yeah I just uh I watched or I listened
to a podcast about the Donner Party from
the last podcast on the left and let me
tell you this seems very much like what
they might have had to go through in
terms of cannibalism and even each other
but they didn't have a leader like
whoever I'm playing but it seems like
look at your mind might be sorry well I
got caught underneath me don't ask you
don't want to know all right Chris are
want to slow your horse down got it all
right I'm good let's go see what the
dealio is anybody over here that we need
to shoot oh wait no I'm Arthur
[Music]
hmm you need to help me pick the others
back up you're the only one I can rely
on to stay strong right now
oh is that someone coming towards us oh
hey well now you back off now you back
up hey wait a minute who's there
oh is it John Marston Mike I think so
found a little homestead down thataway
okay anyone home
sure place is place and applied and
noise sounded like a party let's go see
follow me
Davey doing you didn't make it nor did
little Jenny that's too bad
Davey was a real fighter both of them
calendar boys is her was yeah
Shawn we don't know why a business good
god this is beautiful
can I just stand for a second that this
is goddamn gorgeous
it'll be fine
things always turn out for ya Mac and
Shawn are still out there somewhere -
yeah let me take the rear you move up
okay
huh
oh wait okay gentlemen it's just up
ahead okay sure thing Mike yeah okay I
got a bad feeling we're up to no good
please head down there okay what you say
is what I do also can I point out that
everything Micah says is just sounds
like complete sarcasm so I don't trust
him even a little bit but maybe that's
just a character no no no but also this
is just god damn gorgeous every part of
this every ounce of this game is
beautiful it's so pretty I've never seen
oh sorry
hey whoa whoa hey whoa just cuz I do a
little horse butt bump and don't mean
you got to make no fun of me okay I hate
job broaching very slowly coming in oh
yeah there we go
Oh Mikey you were right there's a lot of
noise that does sound like a party we
don't want to scare these folks yeah
okay yeah we don't want to scare them
okay all right let me just go in guns
blazing don't fear me
you to get yourself out of sight only
man it's a lot less intimidating than
three nasty looking degenerates ok this
cabin shed this cowshed or our one to
take cover I got a funny feeling that um
this looks a lot more suspicious than
what you had intended I got a funny
feeling that uh this uh this good leader
here is gonna meet an untimely end lost
in the storm we can't help you mister
keep your eyes on Dutch no hang on now
Fran for March okay no I don't like this
damn comb this goes his pants okay okay
okay bang-bang up all be a banger
bonilla bang ha ha ha ha ha
oh wait no I miss a bang good thing it's
got some auto aim here or else I would
truly be in trouble oh god I'm just
having a keyboard let me get you I'll
get you
now you get up from a shot to the heart
like that bang boom who where where who
who are you talking about who you're
talking about
take a run after the outlaw I don't even
see an outlaw I'll take a leisurely
stroll no no no no I wanted to get him
okay alright then I'm still crouched cuz
I'm just suspicious about this whole
enterprise some don't rub me right about
this everything rubbing me wrong okay
you got it boss yeah that's what I'm
talking about okay
okay these are not baked beans love this
baby okay alright take
okay open my satchel this is a good
tutorial I gotta admit this is not the
worst tutorial in the entire world I'm
gonna eat some baked beans as well moon
can and all its some extra iron to wash
it down I don't see there's a big price
on como Driscoll's head nearly as big as
the one on yours yeah dad
about the only thing me and Uncle Sam
agree hey some goodies classic outtakes
what does that even mean
revolver cartridges man I ain't in no
hurry you're such a good leader she's so
concerned about everybody how do I run
again oh hey okay I figured out how to
do that
okay well I'm looking for huh excuse me
don't mind me doing that I don't know
what classic Oh oat cakes not outtakes
well I'm dumb I was looking for comedy
and it was food okay well I don't know
where to go I got blood is that good I
still don't know how to sprint there was
wait no I do wha ha ha you know I'm just
walk I just real sassy about everything
I'm doing
there we go chest this is what I was
looking for
all right coin purse okay whatever I
didn't find any whiskey but you know
I'll take the money I guess hmm I don't
think there's nothing else left to get
so gonna do cheer okay don't mind me
just like to push open doors to keep him
on their cutsies pop open this one
Micah Arthur keep looking for stuff okay
you got it boss is this the barn or is
this an outhouse I think this might be
known as okay never mind I was wrong for
the barn
oh that barn over there how do I run I'm
really trying to that's how I look
backwards oh that's how you run okay
mium silly me am silly man
me am silly big silly is there a horse
about to explode out of this probably
hey horsey don't be spooked I'm just a
big scary man hi put my gun out for some
reason hey hey hey you don't know that
okay well don't ski those kids those
skis oh those kids those kids those kids
those kids hey come on you wanna you
want some of this want some of this huh
come on some of this Oh what you're
trying to block your head your head okay
there buddy your pretty face gonna get
full fist bonk a Blanc no all right fine
then what are you doing here hey where's
Cole I didn't even need to beat you but
another one around to other questions
some train gonna blow the tracks
he's just given me everything well one
for good measure all right you're done
okay listen I about that you sure about
that you sure yeah all right you're good
get out of here you goof I'll ever pick
up my gun what did you do dirtied my gun
my god he could have grabbed that pick
up my hat
oh you dirtied my hat I should have
choked the life out of you I should have
go to water
I should have could have water but I
didn't because I'm kind a lot of a whoa
busy my hands here comes a strange man
[Music]
let me give you a good ol slap well
nothing likes more slaps horse bonding
achieved ah let me give you some more
slaps no okay fine then no no no I'm a
lead lead there we go
continuing to bond with your horse
increases its trusting you and improves
its attributes okay whatever you say
we just play rope-a-dope behind my back
yeah figured you won't get far in this
anyway that looks like a decent horse
you should keep them get that horse
hitch don't want a Bolton okay whatever
you say boss hey what's happening what's
happening hi it is gonna be okay we mean
you no harm
this
okay they just had to burn down the nice
house god damn it
of course you did Micah you big fool you
sarcastic piece of poop you burned down
the whole house
what do you crave a nightdress knife
lady
you come with us yes it's okay we're bad
man yank them yeah it's okay get on
we'll keep you safe until you figure out
what you wanna do yeah nice fair's fair
miss miss Adler badly Sadie and misses
hey he was my husband
[Music]
there we have it everybody the opening
sequence the opening tutorial all
wrapped in one storytelling back and
that's what I call vicious somebody's
coming hey whoa wait whoa it's okay guys
it is he weren't the first calm
O'Driscoll and his scum they beat us to
it
we found some of them there there is
more about apparently apparently
scouting the Train
thank you that's the last thing we need
right now judge well it is what it is so
we found some supplies some blankets a
little bit of food then this poor soul
mrs. Adler miss Tilly miss Karen would
you warm her up give her a drink of
something and mrs. Adler it's gonna be
okay
you're safe now they turned her into a
widow animals I need some rest I haven't
slept in three days
Paul you're over here miss O'Shea I'll
show you the way Oh mr. Morgan we put
you in a room over here
thank you miss cream shop mr. bell
you're with the fellas over there well
how come Arthur gets a room when I get a
boat bed next to Bill Williamson and a
bunch of [ __ ] catch yourself too man
Michael what a charmer that guy what a
real go-getter what a winner you know
always appreciative of everything that
he gets in life always burning down
houses maybe you would have gotten room
if you hadn't burned down a house played
ring-around-the-rosie with a scared lady
god damn it Micah we've been seen in
days who ain't been seen Andy smart
strong at least gone
hello Abigail Arthur how you doing just
fine Abigail you I need you to I'm sorry
I'm sorry to ask this little John he's
got himself conned to scrape again ain't
been seen in toots two days your John
will be fine
I mean he may be as dumb as rocks and as
dull as rusted iron but that ain't
changing because you got caught in some
snow storm please go take a look heavier
yes
heavier will you ride out with Arthur to
take a look for John you're the two best
fit men we've got now she's poor old
never pretty worried about him
no no the situation were reversed look
for me maybe you don't know that if this
is John Marston we're talking about what
kind of John which John who John
[Music]
never look back you wouldn't leave I
like that wouldn't be the first time
interesting set piece to move on to
exactly after the initial opening cuz I
didn't know if this game was gonna be
focused on John Marston like the first
game was I mean I think everybody agrees
that when you're playing this game you
kind of need to have that kind of
protagonist I think and spoil alert for
anybody that hasn't seen the first game
come on somebody left
recently recently using
that way wow you are good you are real
good how'd you do that magic tracks you
say okay where are we supposed to go my
god hey waterfall I wonder what I wonder
what would happen if I uh yeah I'm
getting frisky oh babe oh wait oh well
oh oh I guess everything's okay I don't
know I'm gonna get my horse I think I
might have totally boned myself is there
like a call horse button there a call
dude uh hang on man
I've got a lot of problems I'm gonna
satchel nope oh boy
um horse nope where's my horse button uh
who okay guys I may have um oh boy I
hang on behind this tree hide my shame
away in this tree here uh hoof okay
horse say hey horsey bar say hey horse
oh no way
whoa horse horse Blitzen horse okay I'm
gonna get over here on the mount you and
we're gonna get out of here okay Oh
buddy dude
but it day shut up Xavier got this off
it's under control just to have a little
bit of a crisis going on what god don't
don't what are you doing me I had a bit
of a problem okay it was crazy
all right whatever you say there sure
sure sure
some don't add up
whoa whoa bad way but it was a bad
situation
hmm I don't know what the bad situation
would have been but it doesn't sound
good no matter what way you do it
gunshot Mack and John both shot - Sean
we don't even know
I'm surprised we escaped at all by the
time you boys showed up from the other
side of town
we're only just holding on cinematic
camera so if you just have cinematic
mode on and you hold down the Run button
you'll just automatically follow trails
that's so cool to change cinematic movie
and change and change and change how do
they do it how do they do it oh that's
not what they say about me they say the
oh my god look at that look at that home
is the camera know to look at that
that's so cool oh my god a little bit
maybe we'll pick up the trail again
it's so pretty hahaha look at this I'm
gonna cry oh it's better than being out
there in real life Oh what Wow I don't
see why what are you talking about let
me change the cinematic angle oh okay
well we got here okay that's probably
not the I hear that John dawn
oh my horse real upset about the stamina
or some horses having a real bad time
about things John says you my horse is a
chance okay alright alright
horse weapons my favorite kind of
weapons alright yeah nope wait no look
I'm trying hang on here we go
No
well they'll want to view your stored
weapons oh well yeah that's what I'm
I've got it now okay away I know how to
play this game I'm good at video games
all right man Xavier let's see what's
going on
dawn dawn
shouldn't we be like shouting for John
why did he go higher up into the
mountains why wouldn't he do the
opposite of that um John Marsden oh the
level of the inner corner okay why are
we doing this this is all oh ho
this is horrible why would we be here
this is the opposite of the where we
should be this is not of the location
that is good stay low under his stay low
um crunching hey John John Boy Johnny my
stamina is empty okay sure just that
easy huh just a tease
that sounds closer now come on we're
coming
we're coming the goods on we're coming
to get you this you way John why didn't
you why why would you do this John why
would you go here call yeah no kidding
it's cold
well you hurry up Oh coz I can't run
John
the miserable that's a few days I know
here take a drink of that new nation
perfect design for this snow
now whatever you say man damn decor is
no longer empty eat and drink to
maintain your pores
ah so my Tumtum is what you're saying I
got a drink bourbon to fill up my Tumtum
and then I can run
[Music]
well that's John where Wow
where
where is he I don't see him
Marsten
Marsten that's part of scratch you got
there never thought I'd say this but
it's good to see you Arthur Morgan
you don't look so good I don't feel too
good neither you so y'all come on
why do I have to carry him what are you
carry like his lower half will cut them
in half to try this way
I'm told Dutch work the right man for
this sure you did
[Music]
it's John it's John oh oh that's not
John that's not John at all I'm pump you
full of shotgun ooh I'm gonna shove my
shotgun up your boy oh you about to get
a face full of shotgun okay I'm a hero
come on Wolfie head on can you live your
skin.you oh wow you take more than one
shot apparently uh yeah hi hi hi hi whoa
okay hang on wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait Wow
that's right that's what I thought yeah
yeah yeah yeah would you go it's to hide
in the wall you scampering we do scamper
yeah you better run yeah you better run
that's what you get that's what you get
from the messing with the likes of me
yeah can i skin these things there's a
nice pelts out of them
no I can't I skinned oh whoops oh you
rolled over oh good my horse
[Music]
horse I'm gonna go mount my horse I got
moderately mauled by uh by whatever but
it's okay cinematic cinematic no not
that sin
you ain't gonna die now your
[Music]
I mean I feel like it would have been
better off with my pistol in that
encounter but whatever I got my shotgun
so it's all good I couldn't take your
pelts but it's more of them oh no you
don't wait bang boom ha ha ha ha ha
you follow though Wow oh oh wait can I
please keep going
I'm please how do I make sure I keep
going in to visit the same thank
goodness for audio wave
thank goodness I'm bad at all I'm a run
you over
gonna be okay we have some shelter now
thanks for coming forward Boris that
bullet in black water now this got a
hell of a time North always says look
hey the busts are lucky right now so
ride in the water for a bit try to lose
the same don't want to leave the trail
right back to camp you know
we're gonna need to come up with a
better story scarf
freezin
[Music]
the dad thing good enough for you
crossed to the left
wait
I think that just made a connection from
the first game was it John Marston
looking for Arthur in the first well
Cindy looking for Arthur wasn't it just
like Arthur I think I distinctly
remember that what's that a thing is
this the same Arthur man things are
being connected it's been so long since
I played the first Red Dead Redemption I
thought about going back and playing the
first one just to like catch myself up
this is such a long game I didn't think
that I would ever be able to actually
get through it so not today you and is
discussing with hair Strauss when the
weather breaks suppose we'll have to
keep heading east
I know West is where our problems are
worse come on here Strauss let's get
warm
you all go where Strauss
wherever you are I don't know but this
must be the same Arthur because I
distinctly remember Arthur Arthur you
know John Marcin talks Arthur walking
Ronon for weeks
we found shelter and been resting here
and some old abandoned mine in town
while we wait the thaw hardly the spring
I had been hoping for okay
[Music]
we get we wait when the storm breaks we
move but we're safe here okay warm
enough I guess I guess hmm
doubtful just worried what do you think
Arthur
hey whoa I didn't want to be part of
this so hard to say but I trust your
judgment touch always have always gonna
thank you son
what a good leader what a good man for
Hosea I don't feel that this is honestly
anything new nope we had a bit of bad
luck but then the storm covered our
track so now we wait a bit then we go
back to Blackwater and we get our money
or we get some more money and we keep
heading west go ahead and east for now
for now wolf anonymous we're safe for
now stay strong
Hosea we're safe for now listen what
about you
whoa never cuz you know me son I'm just
getting started
yeah I got a watch we get some money
well they they better send some good men
after us cuz they ain't never gonna find
us but we need money of course does oh
thank you son
through your strength it means a lot to
me well my strength means a lot to me
too if I didn't have that I would be a
washed-up sham I wouldn't know what to
do with myself huh huh anyway alright
see ya
I'm just gonna go explore around
Hill for oh hey someone's in here hello
don't mind the fact that I was coming in
here to pilfer just come check this
cupboard the valuables okey-dokey and
the weird creepy doll in the empty
baby's run Oh baby I'm gonna bash out of
this my eye is ready then I'm back in
the game god it's been so long I hope
it's everything I hoped for but god damn
this has been good
say you Xavier are you doing D's on the
lam
you lied have all turned yellow apart
from you of course shut up Michael I
ain't never seen so many long faces I
guess I guess folks miss them I fell but
when I fall I don't want no fuss when
you fall there be a party oh he didn't
even make the joke of you two stop it
now you fools punching each other when
kool Moe Driscoll's needin punching hard
you want to sit around waiting for him
to come find us all are you we got work
to do
come on are you sure about this Dutch
yes through a lot recently we hardly
back on our feet yet and the last thing
we needs to get bushwhacked by kool Moe
Driscoll let's go who's calm Oh Driscoll
hey he's here for us I doubt that nope
you're just doubting me I would never
doubt you touch you you always said
revenge is a luxury we can't afford this
is the right call worth it
take this oh this is about more than
revenge for business long ago they were
talking
about trains and detonators here coal
always had good information come on and
you think now is the right time to hit a
train
now you might fancy living on Deer piss
and rabbit [ __ ]
I do like deer piss too old for that
life mr. Matthews mr. Smith mr. Pearson
would you please look after the place
there are Driscoll's about okay these
goddamn old Driscoll's wherever you look
Oh Driscoll there so Driscoll that
cinematic camera here with God it's so
cool because you know I often harp on
games being like oh it's like you're
practically watching a movie you're not
really playing game but this one is
already blending the both of them oh my
god look at how pretty that is holy [ __ ]
that's the coolest thing I've ever seen
I'm gonna gush about this the whole
goddamn series it's so pretty it's so
pretty oh my God look at the beauty the
beauty the splendor the grandeur hang on
I'm gonna get out of cinematic view
because I want to make sure I got my
pistol they must be you're right boss
you good good
you know I got your back no you know I
always trust you
[Music]
I can't do you killed his brother Dutch
yes damn right me too I said damn right
first I believe in you boss okay must be
you you always ride Dutch you always
ride boss I was believing you boss
you're so handsome boss you got great
tuchus boss
we love the curve of your chin boss you
ain't too old for me boss okay here we
are boss listen I'm just trying to know
the lump against boss can't a guy nozzle
huh do I need to dismount
sorry just wanted to test out my layout
of the huh mr. Williamson mr. Bell hmm
you two take up a hidden position just
outside the camp hmm mr. summers
mr. escuela you two hold position here
huh let's go let's do it boss you the
best boss you got the biggest brain boss
your eyeballs can see for miles boss
boss you got the greatest lips girl boss
I wish I could bury my head in your
bosom boss goddamn boss I love you Dutch
you ain't never done nobody wrong you
ain't never gonna do me wrong in fact
you do me right who you do me right boss
my god you do me right nice binoculars
boss black and gold was always your
colour you like my identical copy I got
I'm such a fan of you boss just please
give me some approval Dutch
definitely they lost I think so yeah
that's lost you own your shooting boss
boss I'll do it I'll go down there I'll
shoot him good boss
look at a guy hoppity skipping away what
a loser
boss he's kidding away boss oh wait I
can move in his boss hang on I'm pretty
uh looking up over here eh there's
somebody who's he talking to
he don't seem very happy why boss you
know he like you boss he ain't the
diplomatic seem to be should we go get
him no home can wait best to get some of
them out of there
and much less fun to rob him and his
score if he never finds out about it
come on let's get down boss you rat boss
boss you ride I'm gonna get down there
I'm gonna show him what for boss I'm
gonna show him what for you always got
the best plan boss oh never hey horse
lend me back that rifle I gave you Dora
my horse got a secret compartment keeps
my weapons nice and warm for me this is
my horse I have no idea
[Music]
let's go we'll search the far side and
go down that way same as Mike and Bill
okay like you said revenge is a luxury
we can't afford alright just wasn't sure
you agreed with me boy sir first LLL
have you completely lost faith in me yes
Oh
right now our supplies equipment and way
out of here everything else including
cold and weight okay there's enough of
those bastards down there to deal with
as it is come on
okay whatever you say boss I mean I'd do
anything for you boss but I thought you
were going crazy there for a second boss
I don't mean to doubt you boss but
goddamn I love this view you took his
boss just want to cover your ear you
know I always got your back
oh and the day you die I'll have your
back mounted above my fireplace woohoo
baby boss okay anyway let's get this
mission underway have you been doing
Pilates boss notice any change one job
this bit steep thanks for the warning
boss you always look out for my best
interest boss oh my god boss do you care
about me should I start shooting people
down there I sure like
Hiten fellas
i'ma start hittin fellas okay whatever I
should take the lead on this they're
going to be gunning for you ya know but
the way our Luck's been running hush
let's just get down there first okay
well boss I don't know what we'd do
without you boss well so maybe we
shouldn't be going in the broad daylight
boss maybe we should have waited for
some kind of cover of night or something
like that to sneak up on him boss maybe
get him when they're sleeping boss now
when they're wide awake you ever think
about that boss alright boss whatever
you say whoa
you ain't gotta tell me twice boss I
always stay I'm trying boss or so
skippity dude quick oh I think he can
see us
I think the way he's looking directly at
us boss I think he can see that's our
guy oh I can take this if you want
oh I've been waiting for this okay Dutch
okay Dutch watch this and 3 2 1 kaboom
weird I thought wasn't that the idea
wait boss I thought I thought the whole
point was that we were gonna be you know
shooting these guys
I thought the idea was that you know did
I goof up buzz boss please don't be mad
at me boss I'm really trying boss
I'll go redeem myself boss here we go
here 31 I've got him
hey hey listen listen whoa that's a lot
of more room than I thought there were
hey you're real close all right listen
hang on wait wait three two one
boom listen watch me watch me don't
worry this flimsy thing will keep me
covered
oh all right boss I thought I thought
that you definitely definitely wanted me
to go charging in guns blazing you said
you want me to lead lead and I took that
as meaning shoot that guy in the head so
if that's not what you meant then that's
your bad not mine and I would never
doubt you boss but I think you might be
losing it a little bit okay let me try
that oh I'll take to ascend the game
wait no wait wait whoa that's not what
I'm we know that's that's what I did
that's exactly what I just did the boss
did you get shot boss no boss
I'm gonna do something Oh
peekaboo
take it off oh I'm like
[Music]
boom ah damn it
oh come on there we go
haha they made it through pretty good
auto-aim stuff on here not the worst
thing in the world
ah no this is not cover is not what one
might call cover
I'm trying hang on and don't shoot me
don't you me don't you me oh wow hang on
hang on hang on
oh god what am i dying god dammit I
don't like the controls of this game I
wish I had a goddamn keyboard not my
fault huh my fault not my fault no boss
sorry there we go that's what I'm
talking all right I get it boss I get it
you're way better than O'Driscoll I get
what
okay well I'm not done looting yet hey
boss hey I'm real greedy boss
[Music]
come come don't you worry boss don't you
worry I'm not hang on oh [ __ ]
we gotta get to who next me
we're not be talking about me
nepeta comedy
I see you on the way that's boss
where's my goddamn gun get your gun out
no not that gun get the gun out whoa
Deadeye we got an advance oh yeah can I
get my goddamn gunner
Oh house not a bad shot if I do say so
myself
geez don't mind me just got a loot very
greedy well that looks like a bad guy
I please get my gun out no not that gun
that's how we work boss okay boss
my guy is that guy enemy I hit him okay
get that guy
[Applause]
I like the way it reloads bullets just
one long tube of bullets that's why I
think I'm firing at them every time
right it's a whole string of bullets
right never I ignore that time that I
charged in and died because I don't know
the controls just 100% yet but I'll get
good baby I don't know if it's actually
worth it to loot all these bodies like
right now I do like it it's a very
satisfying thing though so my favorite
things about the original game is just
being able to loot absolutely everything
tear up all the bodies of all the
animals and woods little sing my taste
into the meat what are we doing boss
sorry buddy what are we doing boss boy
how do we get a lot of these guys one
more and then I'll go over to the boss
and see what he wants
platinum pocket watch holy [ __ ] well
maybe maybe not one more huh got to find
out what the hell's on these guys or
stimulant oh my horse is gonna be so
stimulated open health cure what cure
for health or just generally a health
good enos treat I don't know which one I
prefer this juncture there I got him
okay also before I get to the boss I'm
real toasty I'll be right back I got a I
got coming boss I just had to turn on my
air conditioner you are oh it is too hot
out here tear this place apart I I pour
apart a few bodies my god
[Music]
nice hat all right what have we got here
detonators I don't know if that's
exactly what we're supposed to be
getting here there's something here food
chewing tobacco canned vegetables all
sorts of goodies here's our plans
they all got them strewn out in cartoon
style with big X's and crossbones and
some dynamite right here oh boy oh boy
oh boy oh boy okay nevermind I guess I'm
done there
we got dynamite or just a big old box
that says dynamite
this looks good what do you think mmm
smells good smells real good I'm a curse
you something snort it later a child's
drawing of a train is something about
the train they was gonna ride arrows
miss Cornwall back up let's keep moving
yeah he's like this is the plan boys
trust in me do you doubt me
and these foolproof plans not a man
excuse me sorry sorry sorry I gotta be
near the boss I really gotta be near the
boss yeah oh yeah boss oh yeah
[Music]
this yeah boss oh yeah boss oh yeah
he'll come after us
oh of course he will just like all the
rest
I'm really trying guys hi my horse just
too dumb to get through this boss excuse
me pardon me
I'm just holding the button I'm not
doing any good I love this game I
already love it I can't wait to see some
horrible game breaking physics oh god
there I go some horrible game breaking
physics of the carts just exploding into
the horizon again those the funniest
part of the first game is the absolutely
ridiculous physics I once was skinning a
bear and when I stabbed it the bear just
like shot up
I see wait you talking you talking last
Sobel who you talking last soup last one
good oh you know I'm gonna last through
this guy good I'd also don't like how
that all of the older schools are named
O'Driscoll this guy must be really eager
to stable this is the same guy let live
and I'm gonna antagonize you first swing
swing swing swing
I didn't agonize you today I'm gonna
take your stuff for first now I'm gonna
pick you up
secondly oh yeah here right across the
tuchus and then yeah well guess
something
Oh mommy kicking you the face sorry I
ate a can of beans earlier for you
somewhere you ain't gonna like why what
are you gonna do to me some fan you
ain't gonna like so I advise you to save
your breath for scream wouldn't he be
going no way why are you little weight
cuz this is the horse's ass just like
pressing right in on his diaphragm no
I'll go to Mexico
[Applause]
boy all bosses gonna be so proud of me
for listening
I can't wait to show off balls balls
because I will break every bone in your
body
I'm sorry I'm sorry okay one more
goddamn
clear okay okay that's two bones right
there hmm I should've learned you didn't
learn your lesson that's what you get
you get two bones I'm gonna leave you
with just two bones in your body you're
gonna be a bag of floppy skin and two
bones sorry all right this is the place
wheeze it's our home or is this his home
we just shot up I have no idea I don't
even know how to get to the map kind of
completely forgotten out of play console
games I get spoiled
with PC games now why couldn't this come
out on PC that's what I just gotta say
about that it coulda it coulda but it's
not some reason my boy lefty and my boy
righty and my boy down south come here
you come here Karen hey boys good
welcome to your new home hope you're
real happy here you want me to make him
talk oh no now all we'll get is lies
uncle mr. Williamson
tie this maggot up someplace safe we get
him hungry first I got a sayin my friend
who shoot fellas is neat shootin save
fellas is need Savin and feed him his
need feeding we are gonna find out
what you need I can't believe it
hello Driscoll in my camp Oh whatever
you say son
well done horsey I'm just sorry we
missed out on call
oh there's time enough for that now I
got to figure out if we can hit that
train okay all right all right all right
Oh mission well done everybody mission
accomplished
oh hell yeah I can't believe they go
this gave us so in-depth like it's so
thought out that's the thing about it
it's so fought out all the nuanced
details of it like who spends this much
time they get out of game and who can
possibly keep it all in their head
there's so much that's what I don't
understand about game development it's
just so incredibly incredibly deep
especially games like this that's why
it's so difficult for like one person or
even a small team to accomplish it like
you can sometimes hello
how did we do down here mr. Morgan whoa
Pearson we don't be so good Jesus I just
came over to say hi Sam Buddhist army we
have a few cans of food and a rabbit for
what ten twelve people you know how many
was in the Navy I do not wish to hear
about what you got up to in the Navy mr.
Pierson we were stranded at sea for 50
days and you unfortunately survived when
we ran away from Blackwater I wasn't
able to get supplies in government you
down sometimes shopping trips need to be
cut short
we'll survive we always have they have
needs be we can eat you you're the
fattest
I sent Lenny and Gail hunting and they
found nothing
Lenny's more in the book learning
Bill's a fool unless those mountains are
full of game that want to read ain't no
wonder they've found enough of this
we'll go find something come on Arthur
wait a second hold on here you need some
need out there assorted salted off
starvin will be preferable come on let's
go you don't go hard look at your hair I
can't stay here listening to you two
I'll give this game in those hills I'll
find it and you can kill it you need to
rest Charles you think this is rest
come along hmm
fair enough I like a guy that earns his
keep God why do you want to keep him
down man this this whole group just
loves each other I think this is what
John Marston was talking about in the
first game I can't use it you'll have to
oh you're joking use a gun I will scare
off every animal for miles around but
this is what John Marston must have been
talking about about how like the whole
crew is a family and then things went
wrong that's what this is setting up
right now this is that whole family this
is everybody that he went to hunt down
is in this group here it'll be fine in a
day or two I just can't pull a boat
right now yeah
I never really got the hang of it you'll
be fine so you reckon we're gonna find
something to kill it ain't no Driscoll
I'm hearing there's meat up here for
sure
Pearson doesn't know what he's talking
about now the weather's eased off a bit
they'll be needing two feet it's still
cool I got it's so cool
I keep getting enraptured just by the
the visuals of it like how pretty it was
cuz it is my god but also like God it's
so weird because I'm getting a little
bit icky suppose you've had a lock put
on you I wish I could have done more I
didn't mean it like that just learn to
think back home I still don't really
know what happened on that boat
[Music]
Edge's it automatically I didn't do that
they must know that we're in for a long
trip but it's so cool because I'm
getting bits and pieces of this story a
little bit at a time which is great
because I like it when a story is so
strewn out and it's not like anybody
needs to tell the expedition this is
just life like that's the cool thing
about the stories it is so immersive and
it feels like you're just a part of the
experience like that's what I love about
it and that's all this is struggle I
mean not that I want to live in these
times but there's something romanticized
about it that's just like man living off
the land eaten salted big testicles oh
look at the horse balls as you go
through the the snowy Tundra yes
beautiful it's beautiful also if you
didn't know I'm not joking about the
horse balls thing they literally
animated the horse testicles into this
game because people complained about the
last time of course like that one scene
where the guy grabs the horse bowl
healthy healthy horse okay but then like
there's no horse balls any other time
but if I look down I think I can spy me
some horse testicles
there's the balls
I think I saw balls those balls we get a
good sneaking look okay don't mind me
being weird I'm just trying to inspect
the health of my horse turns out a very
healthy very healthy all right so I need
to get
iq don't need to repeat yourself so much
I know bow horse slow horse get down bow
horse stay low
you got it buddy I'm gonna give me a
deer oh I'm gonna give me a deer oh and
I'm gonna skin the deer no I don't you
go lie track oh my god I am just a
goddamn genius here we go focus on
aminal god okay Oh trust you me I'm oh
definitely get my eye doodly-doo
doodly-doo wait it's gonna be later
today I'm on the case
gonna hunt me your dear boss is gonna be
so proud of me are you ready with that
bow can I call him dear little dears and
on the string before release me just
don't know it Oh quick before they move
up come on you're making yourself too
obvious whoa bed oh dear phenomena dude
did it deer phenomena did did it deer
phenomena did did it did it but that
about if I buy that for some reason for
some reason the deer don't like
whistling
I'm gonna get it this time don't you
worry no your where I'm gonna get it
nowhere to go this way
ah let's see it is it I see it I see it
I say we get up on this rock here that's
right there behind the tree
there it is oh I get it
oh so you're only supposed to do the
thing with the thing to raise their head
and then they run off oh I see okay okay
let's do this well I see yeah
wait dude wait is that the same one did
we not get did we not get a good hit
i'ma get you what I'm doing about to hit
a deer yeah you know what it probably is
probably as buck or any what I can't
skin it what I can't skate I'm real bad
at whistling I can't do it my lips ain't
made for that my lips only made for
kissing and docking no whistling
happening hey dear horsie I got your
present it's a more different type of
horsey there you go just come from all
right well two deer should feed us for a
good while few days at least it's not
bad man what do those other fools do
when they were going out there stupid
[ __ ]
the land it's still all part of the
tutorial that's so funny we're like an
hour and a half into this game and it's
still teaching you that's because
there's so much to do in this game I
made my favorite thing about the don't
say probably right and even if we do get
off here what that still have a big
price on our heads
hell yeah man I love this crew yeah
we're a bunch of outlaws doesn't even
bring a crew good then we caught more
than one
we've only been up here a few days and
have already picked up two more mouths
to feed
one more and nutrition Allah damn say
hey so maybe they can assault and all
fish was kind enough to give us
the girl she has a wild look in her eye
course she lost her husband our home
everything she had so what do we do with
her no I should get out of here we're
back on our feet we'll see my family
somewhere who knows maybe she'll deal
with your dress before
so much more useful maybe we can get to
them before they get to us what is it
with your Driscoll's right there with
them I suppose yeah we ain't run into
them much last six months I guess
because they've been over this way yeah
I've heard a lot of talk about them well
leaving scrapping over scores dam for
years big a nasty sons of [ __ ]
their leader home and debts go way back
not in a good way a proper blood few so
I heard watch out behalf ahead Oh see if
we can find another way around no no no
no no come on now wait let me get out
cinematic you hungry look look look man
look back I don't know what you're
talking about a war animal Sasebo winner
look look have you bad idea yeah look Oh
seen the size of it yeah I've seen the
size of have you seen the size of my gun
I'm a shooter right up the bunghole
okay I miss oh no my god
holy [ __ ] five six months something like
that but he didn't expect this what
Blackwater mess
being up here sooner or later
job's gonna go wrong natura life I just
told you about it moved on by now you
want me to move on
oh no no no no you can run it alone no
problem I did that for a long time I'm
done with it always wondering if
someone's gonna kill you in your sleep
I still wonder that most nights I reckon
you're okay this suits me sure I could
fall in with another gang but Dutch
you know Dutch is different oh yes
that's just certainly different you
treats me fair most do you do for a
fellow with a black father and an Indian
mother
that ain't normally the case well we
need you now
more than ever good and how long have
you been with these boys why don't you
run off hey want to hear something like
that since I was a boy 20 years yeah
tell me to read
huh I'm sure that saved me save most of
us
that's why we need to stick by him
through this
the Oh a Caesars right
what a good guy that Dutch I got a
feeling it's all gonna either turn sour
he's gonna die
[Music]
I appreciate you that may take time even
the early night
she's a strong one it's been as hard on
the horses as on the rest of us I don't
know what Dutch would do if something
happened to the count same with Bill and
brown jack he's a drunk miserable
bastard but he loves that horse I hope
they all make it I tried to ride the cow
once hook me faster than a bull won't
take nobody for him
gods the amount of writing in this game
the amount of voice acting in this game
it's like in any game like this it's so
indent it's so incredibly oh my god
whoops wait no it's way my hitch not in
hex you show me how to use the bow
proper how do I hit I forgotten how to
hitch there we go I'm hitching okay you
got a hold
oh is that poop oh is that pee pee house
is pooping peepee
oh god why is there so much booboo BB
nobody make fun of the fact that I
called it poop will beat me why is there
so much hey Pierson well where we all
need oh I love the way the snow collects
oh so cool find a camp rat loitering
around in the kitchen anyway to greet an
old friend feel like we haven't spoken
for days I do my utmost to avoid you
love me really sadly of showing
affection no it isn't now shoot get lost
well see you gents later see you got on
just fine
Charles is a wonder have a drink boys
your end it changes what is that
maybe rum sir it's the only thing the
only thing keeps you saying it does it
give the dog a treat on you if you go
restaurant hands off I'm gonna be fine
in a few days you mind helping me with
the skinning mr. Morgan it's easier if
we do it together we'll get to skin you
you always won with the jokes aren't you
ask me isn't a job from now on the
burhan I'll see you both later Bob I
don't know why this is my favorite part
I really don't know why this is my
favorite part of the old one like
something about it was just so
satisfying even if its vicious and
brutal but something about it these
supposed to work that easily whoa
they always said you were a butcher you
know you could trade these sell these
pretty much any town if you look at the
maker legitimate bit of money of course
right now I'm just looking to get off
this mountain alive well if you catch
anything else you bring it to me sure
thank you mr. Morgan heck Arthur
Morgan's first decent bit of hunting
after all these years everyone's got to
do their bit to survive just make these
good stew needed a few days never mind
now they removed all the fun out of
skinning that that's horrible I mean
it's the reality of it but still a few
days later she unlocked the Master
Hunter challenge check your log for more
information about a few weeks Dutch
being Dutch he is busy making plans yeah
yeah that's being Dutch those plans
involved robbery and dreams
John Marston who the hell is Leviticus
course I thought you was reading his
last rites
now I see you're introducing him to your
other passion
Oh mind you to show me some respect mr.
Morgan mind away Reverend you're still
here there oh yeah and you'll pay me for
the moment just rest
poor sir I think it's time for the Train
want me to come of course I do but look
at the bull we wanted to see you John
you see me now what's left of me what
about you yes I was hoping to see a
corpse budget time you'll see plenty of
it you're a rotten man John Marston is
an idiot Abigail we all know it now
railway man bill now you ride ahead and
set the charge at the water tower just
before the tunnel ain't a problem why
are we doing this weather's breaking we
could leave I thought we was lying low
yeah come on you want from me Hosea I
just don't want any more folks to die
Dutch we're living hosea we're living
look at me for living even you but we
need money everything we has in
Blackwater you fancy heading back there
no listen Dutch I ain't trying to
undermine you I just I just want to
stick to the plan which was to lie low
then head back out west now suddenly
we're about to rob a train what choice
have we got and the video gets
Cornwall's no joke Duchy who is the
finish Cornwall who is the railway
magnate sugar dealer oil man well good
for him sounds like he has more than
enough to share dad gentlemen it is time
to make something of ourselves get your
horses ready we have a train draw I'm
ready boss boy you know how to rouse the
boys boss
I'm ready go boss gimme one of
all my time is your time I live to serve
you boss and I will die to serve you I
will to the ends of the earth boss god I
love right now with you boss oh I can't
wait to ride this Rob Rob train train
Rob oh that's how you do it double tap X
to move up the formation okay
[Music]
I'll take the driver an engineer then
run point Lenny I'm here to take the
front cars deal with any guards Arthur
and mica you head straight for the back
that's what we're after mister
Cornwall's private car
you and me Morgan Bray have you got a
problem with that
not if you keep your heads or watch you
worry about yourself
no boss I was listening I'm gonna be
perfectly honest I was looking at the
scenery I was smiling it's having a good
time I was enjoying myself cos goddamn
is this this is a slice of something
special and my god is it cool this game
I'm so happy
okay I know why cuz game is awesome it's
living up to my expectations still
learning a great experiencing really
fulfilling in a lot of ways because
about in depth it is and how rewarding
it is to come after a long period of
time to come back to a game that's been
improved in a lot of ways and makes it
more interesting and more engaging in a
story that's captain oh my God look at
that
anyone gets up here after us oh look at
you boys see this is what I call it
through
my charles smith and what about John
Mulaney here always the first man on his
horse just happy way back out of Dutch
you're sure you're ready for this gig
course I'm ready
just stay calm keep your eyes sharp that
goes for all of you
no mistakes not again so we do this then
we go back to Blackwater to collect
how many times you guys same question
market that's a lot of damn money to
leave sitting for too long it would be
crazy to go back there now the place
will be swarming with Pinkertons we go
back what I say we go back and that's
the end of it the money sink you'll just
have to trust me
and if the O'Driscoll's are right w
stack of railroad bonds on this train
once we work out how to cash every boss
I don't want to point out but you were
the only one talking boss really this is
gonna be pretty cool
does he look pretty cool I mean I'm
saying he's gonna be pretty cool
he's build there yeah you want a head
down see how he's getting on okay
okay boss I would rather stay up here
with you head down
Oh figured out how to do that I don't
know what the point of that is but I
figured out how to do it I'm combing it
bill coming to bail bail bill you blow
up this yet bill bill bill of course a
little all right go ahead and set up the
detonator buy those rocks over there
okay okay but shouldn't I do this when
you're not holding that there all right
blue booties with screwless we don't use
the handle for the school squeaker bleep
and I've spotted it and there you have
it I just caught this definitely gotta
think about this real hard here we go
[Music]
hit it now now get it now you want me to
hit it now step on this and I hit it now
all right fine whatever
I don't feel like I actually needed help
with this one
I feel like you could have feel like you
could have done this by yourself and you
didn't need to actually have me come
down here to do this feel like me coming
down here to do this is more of a lesson
and not actually something that I needed
to have happened you know mistakes right
what are we doing again what's going on
these days all fine
well soon find out everything okay I
think so
okay cover your faces trains should be
here any minute now
how do I do that hello I cover my face
oh yeah all right cover mine how do I
face cover my face covered boss I don't
know how to cover my face boss oh okay
okay I didn't do it okay there's the
mask good it good it put on the mask I'm
going to include you I'm going to
I'm going to am i stupid here is this
wait l1 hold l1 to show weapon wheel
swished item goddamnit
yeah I was holding it too long okay I'm
a big dumb dummy okay whatever
now they don't know who I am boss boss's
at you
am I gonna know which ones for us good
luck all right we all know what to do
again boss I was not paying attention
the whole plan thing I honestly have no
idea what are we doing now what are we
doing oh okay I see
dumpy-dumpy oh did I do that I might
have done that that might have been my
fault I'm out of push you off there that
might have been entirely my fault
oh I gotta do this why do I gotta do
this why can't you pull yourself up okay
he found near the zoo
whoa is the hole
oh my god is the hole stabbing people
necessary is that necessary
all right whatever I guess is necessary
all right here we go here we go no no no
no aah no wait whoa hey whoa wait hang
on wait oh I'm just gonna stick my head
under the wheel that that wasn't my
fault
that wasn't my fault that was not my
fault that was not my fault no one
keeping it bad that was not that was
clearly not my fault that was not my
fault in any way shape or form I'll be
very clear though it's not my fault 100%
that was not my fault there we go
all right now let's not do this all
stupid like let's do this all sparkly no
no no okay
oh I got this one sorry I was just
thinking about stuff and things I'm
going what are you talking about I'm
going
I got this you don't see nothing cool
[Music]
ah I just ate that
well I'm a maybe not should have hit
that shot that box of or a barrel of
whatever maybe it was gunpowder
[Music]
well why did he trust me to hook up the
wire then
ok let's get up here
oh um listen good thing you're a bad
shot and I'm not okay I mean I'm a bad
shot but let's not talk about that
[Music]
how about reload again completely
frowned now to reload
[Music]
whoa whoa whoa whoa what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
way way way way way what the [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] I just want Jeff to the right
that's not what I did [ __ ] a controller
god I hate that controller [ __ ] all
right we're going for this time speed
run baby oh hey buddy let's go
well what the [ __ ] again are you
[ __ ] kidding me are you [ __ ]
kidding me oh are you eating my ass
right now are you just exploding my face
are you good God I will eat your
pancreas and I will enjoy it okay all
right here we go again
[ __ ] I'm yeah this is what I'm gonna
do [ __ ] this [ __ ]
[Music]
yeah that's how I want to do it yeah I'm
good too
I shot you in the dick okay let's make
sure there we go
stop this train
ow
just stay calm okay reverse the grapple
I got this how was your ribs taste in
there buddy beat you
yeah I got this Abraham look looking
[ __ ] I got him
huh bap cinematic view just for the fun
of it and he's young who's there huh
hey bye there nobody's there that's what
I thought that's what I thought why
didn't we just do that from the
beginning huh
why we gotta make that complicated
trying to do all this fancy demolition
[ __ ] oh where they come from
[Music]
okay
I'm getting better I mean it's Auto
aiming so it's pretty much just doing it
for me at this point but I'd like to
think see you there
[Music]
yeah yeah I feel like we're robbing the
wrong person here as if this is gonna go
somehow badly for us and then to biting
us in the ass that guy's got a red shirt
he must be important oh well apparently
he's not that boring cuz he did die I
mean we're kind of like two-man army
again so here so I don't think that
there's any chance that they're not
gonna win or we're not gonna win we win
Wow get out my way please we're gonna
lose
[Music]
god I wish I knew how to reload
oh there they are
this guy in orange looks important oh
and I got loot this guy this guy looks
important yeah we did all this without
you guys so um I'm gonna take two
diamond Luke I'm getting my Just
Desserts boss listen I
I literally worship the ground you walk
on
listen to me we don't want to kill any
of you any more of you I give you my
word but trust me we will come on boys
we got okay you asked for it four three
two one team's our friends have gone
death wake them up a little
mr. Williamson's you mr. Morgan and mr.
Smith some dynamite you two boys go blow
that door open oh oh yeah okay
seems good enough now light the fuse oh
you got it you got it
I'm ready oh I'm ready for this okay
will do boss I'm sure we can't rub up
just a little bit what was so important
that they wanted to protect this so
badly I mean I bet I'm gonna find out
but I mean it's it's gonna be it's gonna
be big some letters we are yet to
receive payment mm for the initiative
there's Joe Bob Beauty Indian
Reservation I'll give you as agreed by
the contract Cornwall and Iceland
development okay flip okay all right huh
cigar platinum pocket watch another
letter papers those are the bonds you
idiot oh never mind we all know you can
read mine okay not really
sugar imports from the Spanish West
Indies a lot of sugar some fancy new
bodis ordered from Europe who's in it oh
hello hey I'm onto something here you
might want to come over here those bonds
yeah we're not done here just yet let's
look at everything nothing there all
right we're good here I suppose this is
what we came for why wouldn't they keep
it in the safe why wouldn't they keep
what they really needed in the giant
safe and in a small lockbox outside is
where the value oh sure
bearer bonds I think we could probably
sell these pretty easily well done then
would you get rid of all of this train
yeah get it out of here about them what
are you thinking I don't know it's up to
you kill them leave them here take them
with you on the train just make sure
they don't send no folk after us okay
see you back at camp when you get back
we'll be moving on the rest of you let's
ride wait wait wait wait wait whoa wait
whoa hey whoa wait listen listen listen
listen listen listen listen listen
listen okay get on the train quick why
do i why am i left alone
kill all three so behave get on the
train here so much is a footstep from
this car you'll end up like all your
friends out here wait
something something don't feel right
they could just run for it what what's
their incentive not to just run for
right now why did they leave me alone
with why didn't mike why am i alone
dealing with this they could jump me I
mean I'm capable but also at the same
time it feels like that might be a
little unfair huh I ain't so sure about
this okay
all right I guess ha
something don't rub me right about that
I'm a little confused about the
execution of that strategy but okay
we'll leave it at that then peculiar and
a loading screen which I haven't seen in
this entire endeavor not since the
beginning of this game have I seen a
loading screen oh there we go
Maribeth we're gonna try weather seems
stable and we just robbed the laviticus
Cornwall train we got money in our
pockets the worst is behind us gentlemen
so the question is I know this a little
I told you we should set up camp in
Horseshoe overlook near Valentine we'll
be able to hide out there no problem
as long as we keep our noses clean well
then let's go clean noses and everything
else Arthur you're in that one bring
Hosea I know you two like to talk about
the good old days and what's gone wrong
yeah yeah boss we sure do you are out of
your gourd that is true oh my god look
it's ridiculousness look this
ludicrousness look it's absurdity
absolutely this word donk
[Music]
Oh
so pretty
god is so pretty that's the thing like I
just cannot get over how pretty the
series and I think the game developers
probably knew that like the play testers
going through this over and over again
over like every time it gets a little
bit better they're just like my god that
is flippin beautiful
I just love it when a something comes
together and I know it's probably the
product of a lot of overworked employees
and a lot of like very question I mean
with the boy just go come on kids you
can buy me a whiskey
this is feel right you know
feels like it's the work of tried
because you know this game like it's not
designed in the same way that a lot of
games are that they're supposed to be
just this like epic thing that you know
everybody can grow accustomed to III
feel like this almost started as a niche
thing but god I'm so happy about it but
anyway that is where I'm gonna end the
first episode of this expect more to our
episodes of Red Dead Redemption - coming
at you very soon
thank you everybody so much for joining
me I am having a blast a blasty blast
the blast ease blast playing this game
and it is awesome
so let me know what you think down the
comments below I don't have a
playthrough of Red Dead Redemption 1
sorry I played it before I started my
youtube channel but it is just a delight
so thank you again and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye